we are chopping down the thicket of
unnecessary federal regulations by which
government too often interferes in our
personal lives in our personal business
when President Trump
bragged about cutting red tape during
his first State of the Union address we
have undertaken a historic effort to
massively reduce job crushing
regulations the Democratic response was
hardly a surprise but Democrats may be
surprised to learn that at the dawn of
the deregulation year in the 1970s it
was their party pushing to cut red tape
and shut down entire federal agencies
the leading figure in the fight to slash
the state was none other than Jimmy
Carter there is a limit to the role and
the function of government it was
Senator Ted Kennedy who held extensive
Senate hearings in the early 70s with
testimony from the likes of Ralph Nader
and liberal economist Alfred Kahn about
the benefits of deregulating the airline
industry the resulting airline
deregulation Act of 1978 signed by
Carter killed the Civil Aeronautics
Board a federal agency that decided
which airlines could fly where and even
what they could charge the new
competition to the old airline cartel
reduced fares expanded destinations and
made air travel an option for those of
us who aren't rich on southern there's
only one class of service and it isn't
second Carter also lifted stifling
government oversight of the rail and
trucking industries under a Democrat
controlled House and Senate results
competition intensified prices dropped
and consumers saved more money on
everyday products we've deregulated the
air industry the rail industry the
trucking industry financial institutions
in 1978 President Carter signed into law
a bill that lifted Prohibition era
criminal restrictions on home brewing
fully legalizing do-it-yourself beer
production fostered a culture of
experimentation paving the way for a
craft beer revolution beginning of the
1980s and 90s the year that Carter
loosened the rules the US was home to a
mere 50
breweries today there are over 5,000 in
two generations America went from global
laughingstock to world leader producing
the richest lagers and tastiest ales the
Governor of California during Carter's
presidency was none other than Jerry
Brown then known as governor Moonbeam
for his far-out musings glittery social
life and lefty politics yet Brown too
could be a fiery skeptic of government
and there is an overblown rhetoric and
an overblown expectation that if there
is a problem there must be a program to
solve in his legitimately awesome second
inaugural address back in 1979 Brown
said that quote many regulations
primarily protect the past crop up
privilege or prevent sensible economic
choices the idea that government has
some old Nipponese our emissions is
completely absurd and counted on all the
thinking that went into this country so
air travel is now competitive though it
should be more open to foreign
competition dammit and the beer industry
has been reborn but since the dawn of
the disco era governments at the local
state and federal levels have imposed
entirely new categories of regulations
such as occupational licensing which
applied to about one in ten jobs 40
years ago but now affects one in three
Arizona for example will put its
citizens in jail for six months for
operating a blow dryer without a license
Texas wants to make it a criminal
offense to buy pecans without proper
authorization and Washington DC wants to
require that all day care providers have
a college degree the aggregate cost of
these regulations is staggering
last year according to the free market
competitive enterprise institute federal
regulations alone cost Americans one
point nine trillion dollars or about 15
grand for household and while Trump has
cut the number of pages in the federal
register by about one third since he
took office there are still some 67
federal departments agencies and
commissions currently working on over
3,000 new regulations it seems you can't
stop the regulatory state you can only
hope to contain it it's out for Conn and
his liberal contemporaries could have
explained licensing boards tend to be
dominated by industry incumbents who are
mainly interested in
their own turf regulation is the friend
not enemy of big business so what has
changed over the years about the party
of Bernie Sanders Elizabeth Warren
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez Democratic
support for deregulation was partly born
out of desperation in the age of
stagflation cutting red tape to foster
dynamism was about the last move
politicians had left by acting now we
can control in our future instead of
letting the future control us so in the
long economic expansion and stock market
boom we enjoy now ends and it will the
best thing for lawmakers of both parties
to ask themselves might just be what
would Jimmy Carter
[Music]